today on the anime's owner a view of
panty & stocking with garterbelt japan's
attempt to paying homage to american
cartoons while making a comedy anime
with many references to american media
now for japan looking from the outside
in I wonder what kind of humor they
think America would really like oh I
don't want bad you dick I want good old
dick you have a massive erection dig dig
dig dig dig dig dig sorry I can't hear
you over the sound of my giant throbbing
erection talk
[Music]
[Music]
ever since anime started getting semi
popular in the West there's always been
some kind of rivalry between American
cartoon fans and anime fans anime fancy
cartoons is either childish shallow
dribble that doesn't hold a candle when
it comes to telling a story or as a
bunch of adult sex humour shows with the
substance of a spoon and cartoon fancy
the others as a conglomerate of weird
perverted tentacle rape fantasies with
the same three frames of animation
consisting of a fanbase who spent way
too much time for their pillows so who
knew that one day some Japanese guy
would get drunk off his tips and decided
would be a great idea to make a raunchy
sex filled comedy anime with an art
style that looks like some cartoon sets
in an acapella swimming dimension
starring a black priest a goth and Paris
Hilton but that's exactly what penis and
sex jokes with gangbang is all about now
meet the fallen angels Panty and
Stocking the UH narky sisters who got
thrown out of heaven because they were
somehow too offensive with our
foul-mouthed uh ninja-like behavior and
general attitude about giving a [ __ ] or
apparently too many as punishment they
are now trapped in the purgatory of
dancing city where the show follows
their daily adventures of killing ghosts
taking names kicking ass and chewing
bubblegum or condoms apparently under
the guidance of garter belts they use
their heavenly powers to transform their
divine panty and stockings into holy
weapons that they used to battle the
evil monsters of [ __ ] the wicked beast
of snot and what dumb [ __ ] am i reading
yeah so much organics or smoking
snorting or injecting when making this
book that's as much sense as a plot
synopsis is ever gonna make because
trying to sell Pantene stocking for a
story is a bit like trying to sell porn
for its cinematography well the show is
really about it is over-the-top zaniness
and vulgar humor as a homage to american
animation and a parody of western media
the first thing people notice about this
anime is that it looks nothing like a
[ __ ] anime the All Star resembles
Powerpuff Girls on crack and mostly
consists of 10-minute one-off
monster-of-the-week type stories in the
same format as something like Dexter's
Laboratory and has minimal continuity
until the final few episodes each
episode is pretty formulaic where the
news goes to ping which I main do only
to kill which they go about doing in
various ways when they're not busy
parroting transformers taking a stab at
high-school movies or reenacting the
opening sequence to Saving Private Ryan
with sperm Saving Private Ryan with
sperm
yup yeah panty a typical feisty blonde
but a foul-mouthed who transforms her
underwear into guns while fighting
ghosts look she's much rather spend all
her time partying and finding different
guys to [ __ ] her sister stocking is an
equally lazy Gothic Lolita with an
obsession for sweets whose power comes
from her stockings that she transforms
to use as katanas garter belt completes
the trio off a black priest with an afro
who has a secret obsession for bondage
and molesting little boys haha
his job is to keep the Angels under
control and the only real thing missing
about his character is that he didn't
get voiced by samuel l.jackson no a
fetch feature man but Jesus God what is
that what happened here was a miracle
and I want you to [ __ ] acknowledge it
now here's why hits a roadblock in this
review because you know what this is a
comedy anime and how funny it is will
vary from person to person because
comedy is such a subjective thing so the
best thing I can do is just describe to
you and hope that you gets an idea of
whether it's your type of humor or not
in a nutshell it's crude and
unrestrained housing every kind of
immature joke in the book which is
ironic considering this is meant to be a
mature show when I would say that the
humors anything but hehe but and here's
exactly what I mean the basic formula
big joke for an episode is to either
parody or reference a popular Western
theme [ __ ] while throwing in swear
words or sexual jokes every other line
vagina there's not that much thought put
into the writing since moisture are just
as lowbrow and vulgar you can get [ __ ]
and while this may be amusing for the
first few episodes penis can get kind of
grating after a while since there's no
subtle teachers and it's just the same
thing every episode giant erection with
a different setting bollocks
the jokes are just too repetitive and
predictable to get hard laughs out of me
even though I have stated numerous times
that the almighty secret of breaking
into the Western audience is just to add
a lot of dick jokes unless you are smart
and sophisticated like me of course I
can writes really clever and witty jokes
I have a boner boner boner you have to
know what to expect when going into this
guy likes knew its target demographic or
a bunch of complete [ __ ] like me and
it's the perfect anime to just switch
off the brain and let that immature
14-year old teenager slip out and run
wild for a few minutes but that's not to
say that the dick jokes are the only
thing the show is going for it the spite
is simple art style the show actually
has some very decent and fun action
scenes spread throughout with one of the
highlights being the over-the-top
catfight mid series and it's little
things like this like somehow gives it
an
anime taste despite being so westernized
though there were times when the quality
of animation really did drop down to
flash animation level another plus was
that the soundtrack was great mostly
consisting of catchy electronic Tunes
which perfectly matched up to the fun
feel of the show and while we're on the
subject of sound the dub for the show
was amazing I did everything it needed
to do I honestly can't imagine enjoying
the show as much if I watched it subs
and for such a vulgar show the dub held
nothing back often adding to it and
hearing the battery in English which is
so much funnier than trying to read it
from that fancy bakery and you managed
to do this without saying another [ __ ]
word
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay you see the playback
you could obviously tell how much fun
the voice actors were having when
recording this and it shines through
with their performances on top of the
fact that this is such a westernized
anime it's a no-brainer that this is one
show that should be watched dubbed all
this adds up to a very entertaining
package that has more going for it than
meets the eye it was fun seeing the
typical stupid transformation sequence
turn into a seductive poured ons
it was a nice little touch that the clay
ghost blow up every time in live-action
as one was killed and just seeing an
anime like this was a breath of fresh
air in itself even if it was trying to
appeal to the American audience so hard
the back of the box art my world just
consisted of the words please Adult Swim
please and a picture of someone bending
over backwards but as an experimental
anime I would say that this was a
success remember that this came from
studio Gainax
the studio that gave us Neon Genesis
budget control a VHD the anime and
Tengen Toppa [ __ ] logic up the arse so
saying that garnets likes to experiment
is a bit like saying the entire cast of
Jersey Shore likes to be [ __ ] retards
but whether it's a hit or miss I can
never stop saying that they put all the
effort into it you can quite clearly
tell the guy next tried really hard with
this and even if it was just full of
dick and sex jokes
they put their heart and soul into
making every [ __ ] sex joke as vulgar
and lowbrow as possible which in my eyes
deserves credit in some weird and
twisted way overall panty & stocking
with garterbelt is a mixed bag with a
few hits and misses but some of the
spread out action scenes and great
soundtrack make it a very entertaining
package overall for me the show is more
fun than funny more entertaining than
laughs out loud and it surely won't
appeal to everyone but if you can let
that immature side of you run wild for a
while
aren't easily offended all watch stuff
with your mom in the living room you
could try giving this a watch
currently Pantheon's talking we've got
two buddies licensed by Funimation and
is also available for streaming subbed
and dubbed on their website and with
that I think I've gone through enough
dick jokes to last me a lifetime so you
know what why don't we switch to some
more refined media for a while just so
we can feel a bit more sophisticated the
government's control of the whole
electoral process rendered the vote
unfair according to Dutch observer tiny
[ __ ] hey guys hope you enjoyed that
review of Panty and Stocking it's been a
while I know but I'm trying to work on
getting more regular videos out whether
it be reviews or rants or reactions and
I'm actually working on a verbage 4.0
now so yeah if this is your first time
watching me then you can check out some
of my other stuff right here and if you
like it you know try and give me a like
subscribe maybe and don't forget you can
also find me on Facebook and Twitter in
the description below anyway that's it
for me now though so I'm gonna go back
to working on some more videos for you
guys so until then I've been gig up and
I'll see you all next time